Okay, so we are doing so as in the past we've been introduced to self-forgift day
name.
My name is Kenneth Hedberg and this is the 20th of October 19th or 2011.
Okay, so today I would like to start with you telling us about the role that you played
in the following papers telling you already today.
Yeah, well we talked about that last time I guess.
Did we or did we know?
Well, I have a uncomfortable feeling I'm repeating myself here but maybe not.
The effort to bring the papers here began when I sat at the head table with the Helen
Pauline during the meeting.
Short in celebration of the awardee of the Pauline award which had been newly set up by
three sections of the American Chemical Society and she told me at that time that people,
several universities and other institutions were after Linus' papers but she said he didn't
want them to go to these institutions.
She said they didn't want all of those papers and the University of Pennsylvania I've seen
you remember as one of them as well as Caltech and Stanford.
They only wanted slick proportions but they wanted them all together.
And so she said to me that she had felt for a long time that the papers ought to come to
Oregon State.
Now this was before Pauline relations with Oregon State had been repaired and she went
on to remark that she'd been talking to him and she was trying to persuade him that
he should let bygones be bygones.
So that was Linus' late year?
Oh gosh, that was the early 60s.
I'm sorry my memory was hazy on these exact dates but anyway, sometime now.
So I conveyed this information when I got back to the institution to President of the
University who at that time was Professor Johnson and he called me and asked me if I thought
that Pauline would accept an invitation to come to the University and speak.
And I said well, it could well be the case it doesn't do any harm to try.
Now have I outlined the reasons before that Pauline did not want to come to the institution
and everything?
Oh, I thought we talked about that.
That's odd because well never mind.
In the late 40s there was a faculty member at Oregon State named Ralph Spitzer who was
denied tenure in the Department of Chemistry.
He was an excellent physical chemist and he raised the issue that he was being fired for
is politically found partly on the letter that he had written that was published in Chemical
and Engineering News.
Not supporting but at least saying that people ought to at least think about what this
fellow Lissenko in that time, the Soviet Union was saying about the effect of environment
on inheritance and of course this flew in the face of conventional wisdom of the time
that everything was inherited.
So at any rate the faculty at the chemistry department decided that they would not offer
him permanent tenure in which men of course that he had to leave.
Now I knew all the members of the chemistry department having been an undergraduate here
and consequence of this was that Ralph Spitzer asked the American Chemical Society for
hearing the issue of, I forgot what the ACS committee was but anyway the idea is that
you're not supposed to be discharged from a teaching position on grounds of your political
beliefs.
And at the 1948 meeting of the American Chemical Society in San Francisco which I attended
Ralph made his case and he was strongly supported by Linus Pauling.
The upside of all this was that I don't think the ACS committee wanted to get its hands
too deeply involved in this thing and not much ever came of it but Pauling was rather
actively pursuing an ocean that Spitzer was a fine scientist and there could be no reason
that he shouldn't be kept on for professional reasons.
Now AL Strand was president of Oregon State at that time and the news media or some media
made it brought up this knowledge of what Pauling had said and Strand got properly angry
and said well Oregon State can get along with outline as Pauling.
And Linus Pauling then said to the media when this was a part of the dream if they can
get along without Linus Pauling they will.
So from 1948 to all through the 50s and of course there was no Popeyes in 1954 and he
spies later on he had nothing to do with Oregon State but after Mrs. Pauling's comment to
me and my relay of this information to Johnson he called me and said as I said before I would
Pauling accept an invitation and due course this was tender to him and he agreed but he
was going to come here and he was not going to speak to the university as a whole not
going to speak to the chemistry department on scientific subject.
So there was a huge meeting held in the present Gilt Hall, C.M. and there was a podium set
up on one side of the floor and Stands were filled on the opposite side as this kind of
a stage.
And the head of time Johnson asked me if I would introduce Pauling.
Well as you think about that here is a distinguished scientist coming to speak to the university
and the present university is not introducing him.
An ordinary faculty member like me was asked to do so.
Well in my presence Pauling and I and Johnson made some other people with our Johnson and
Barnley that I was going to introduce him and he turned to me and he says you're going
to introduce me Ken and I said yes he's asked me to do that.
Pauling didn't say a word but it was perfectly clear that he felt that it was appropriate for
the university president to do the introduction.
Well so anyway all of Mrs. Johnson and President Johnson made a hell of a polling and why
I was some Lisa and I got in the limo and we were chauffeur over to the hall of Sam and
everybody was sitting there waiting we filed in and went up on the stage and a few things
were said and then I rose to give my introduction which I did in a few minutes and about this
time this is Pauling was about to speak and filed a group of students.
They were all black and many prominent among them were many members of the football team
and this was at the time when the great pumpkin had decreased that football players were
not going to be able to wear a beard and at that point all hell broke loose and there were
meetings on the campus regarding free speech and the ability of the students to football
team to have a personal appearance as they wished and the great pumpkin insisted that
he finally resulted I think to saying that the beard didn't fit very well with a helmet
and so on and anyway and due course these people they set a few words and then they turned
and abruptly filed out and very well behaved and so Pauling gave his speech which was on
peace and very well received and so on and then at a dinner that evening Pauling said to me
she said oh that was I was so surprised she said I thought all these flocks that had
filed in were there were they were going to sing well that was the beginning of several
overtures Pauling he came back succeeding occasions but in the middle of all this well not in the
middle but I think at the beginning of all this I had reported to Johnson that Pauling that
Mississippi thought that Melinas' papers should come to Oregon State and of course that would
have been a great coup and so he gingerly broached the subject to Pauling I wrote him a letter about
this actually and Pauling and due course responded and saying that he would give it some thought
that he was not yet prepared to give up his papers because he was still actively using the
materials that were in and after Johnson retired he was succeeded by the picker and I didn't think a
great deal about this Pauling was now coming and doing occasion and it suddenly occurred to me
that I should forward the information that I had given to Johnson to him as well so I dug out
the correspondence that the letter that I had written and President Johnson's response to it
and typed another letter and sent it off to Dr. McPickery. Well this scenario was repeated and he
again queried Pauling on his papers this was now some several years later after the first
literature but he got the same response back Pauling wasn't yet ready to park with these papers
and time went on and John Byrne became president and once again I hold out these papers now
I have two sets of correspondence and wrote to John sent it off to him and his response was
a little bit different immediately he set up a committee on which I served and he made a
concrete offer to Linus Pauling at the others had him he said we are very unparafreshing him now
you could talk to John and find out exactly how this went but the legitimate was that he
said that they would create a they would not just set up a room or something they would create a
special collections in which he could he all of these papers could be housed they would build this
for him for him I think you see I only see these facts from what I remember of our contacts but
I should be checked with John remember the committee was Rob Phillips and some others who
may can't remember now but anyway this went on and this time Pauling agreed this is what would
transpire but he wanted also the homes papers to come as well he strongly felt always
like that after he had won the peace prize that she should have shared in it because he was the
one that actually stimulated his activity in that area well there was a huge when he agreed to do
this the first thing that he did was supply to the university and you'll know all this in the
records of of the special collections he sent the copies of the signatories to the
proposal for the way of holding the petition for banning
exploding explosion of nuclear weapons in the atmosphere atmospheric test bands
and that was the first thing I believe that came to Oregon State and only gradually to the other
materials that appear still because of course when I was Pauling was acting until shortly before
this was a short time before he was down and I remember people here were not
clear about how big this collection of Pauling was and so the Duke course of university suggested
that they come down and take a look at what he had and Christian and earthy was sent down
and he came back and told me I had kind of crosses where his eyes should be says there were over
90 filing cases down that big surre we're Pauling had his ranch you see all the stuff had been
moved down there and he said Christian I think was of Lamesh was just totally blown away by all of this
they say well in Duke course oh after Pauling had agreed to give his papers there was a very
very elegant reception in Portland with several speakers and lavish dinner I was really a very
very nice affair and Pauling spoke and at that stage somehow the question came up about
all of his materials coming here and there had been some feelings some of the family member
particularly Linda I think who felt that the family should have held control over some of these
and Pauling was asked well what does your family think about all this and he says well Linda's
here why don't you ask her I don't remember what a response was what I do remember Pauling statement
very clearly well as time went on these things began to arrive these filing cases now remember
well much describing to me a truck had pulled up and discord your few of these filing cases and so on
and that was a start and that saw the project through to completion I don't know when the last
of these materials actually arrived here special collections but that's kind of the history
of how they came here at least of the role that I played in it doing nothing but reminding one
president after another of what Pauling had had what Mrs. Pauling had urged him to do in the
fact that the relations had been repaired seem to between the university and Linus Pauling seem
to suggest that things might go smoothly forward from there I do know that he was actually very fond
of the university but he came on business which he did not infrequently I usually
somehow involved in escorting him around walking the campus with him and a number of occasions
we walked around campus for one time we walked up in the old who was in those days known as a
chem shack and then quite seriously remodeled from Pauling's time but he seemed to be able to
pick out the room in which he had been lecturing when they even held on Pauling appeared in his life
and we walked down 15th Street and he showed me a house there that he had lived in as a student
and I said to him it's rather surprising because there's a certain parallelism in our experience here
because I lived on 15th Street also only on the other side of the street just to have a
block down and I was an undercrucute student so I took a picture of him in Linda on the steps of the
of the house I have it somewhere in my materials at home so the other thing I would say is that
when Pauling began to come back to Oregon State on occasion we saw him in his life as long
as she was living quite frequently at home for dinner and places and things like that so we got
to know them pretty well better than when I was a student of course when I was a Kel Tech as a student
I was a student I was it so it's been for me a wonderful exhilarating experience
so does that answer your query I've spent 20 minutes describing it?
Yeah well I'm interested in not very giving it a memory of the memories at the time that
maybe on the minus would come up in frequently and you're hosting them?
Oh yeah sure I have I have I have I keep thinking that I have said some of this to you before but
and they have been to somebody else but let me think just a moment one time this is
in the music anecdote and I don't know whether it involved well but I don't remember the
who the host was for dinner party that the Paulings and we were invited to along with Dave
Schumacher who was chairman of our department and who by the way new Pauling very well he was a
student at Kel Tech when I was and we all knew that Pauling he didn't shy away from alcohol he
liked the vodka and on the evening of the dinner party and just before about four o'clock I got
a call from the host sorry about my throat asking me I know that Dr. Pauling likes vodka says I
looked at my cupboard and I don't have any and I don't have any way of getting it do you happen to
have any vodka and I said well as a matter of fact I do have I told this story no well as a matter
of fact I do so I went into my cupboard and I had maybe two thirds of a bottle there and so I
got a brown paper bag put the bottle in it and then we were picked up and the Paulings were picked up
and we were driven up to the whole south right in the doorbell and he appeared and everybody shook
hands and he and it is why I greeted everyone most pleasant clean as I walked in I handed him my
paper bag with a bottle in it and then every minute settled down for a bit in the living room before
dinner was served and the host said well would anybody like a drink and Dr. Pauling said well you
don't happen to have any vodka do you and the host said well as a matter of fact I do
so I thought that was that story I think is very funny and retrospect but
and then he wrote I never told Pauling this history at all
so after either Helen died he continued to come to Oregon State often with Linda
as who accompanied him and they would come there were lots of things set up at the university
of receptions here there's a big library reception one time and there were seminars and chemistry
and even in physics and then usually after these affairs and before dinner well I say usually that
often at any rate he and Linda would come to the house and on one occasion
referring still now to his enjoyment of a drink before dinner
we were on the campus walking around I said what would you like to do now before the next
reception which is a hour and a half way it says as well can we go to your house for a drink and I
said yes we could so we went over to my house and he said you don't happen to have any vodka
I thought I know you like that and so I got a glass a small tumbler like it puts a nice in it
and he drank a drink straight vodka it's essentially pure alcohol you know and he told me at one
other occasion before dinner he always had one of these cocktails but that was about it
so I opened the glass and started to pour and I said say when he didn't say when when the
thing was full I stopped and he looked out and he looked at me with a smile there was a lot of
icing it so we really wasn't an awful lot of vodka I think at any rate we chatted a while and
then he said to me can I have another and Linda was sitting there they had to go this is a time
we had to go to reception over here in the library someplace or another it was a library
reception but it was held in the M U and one of the rooms at the M U and anyway he says can I
have another vodka I put some more ice in and poured again and once again I stopped when it was
full and Linda was over there is a daddy daddy you shouldn't do that you've got to go to a
reception he just smiled at her and then we got up and walked out and he walked straight as a
a lot he didn't waiver at all we got in the car went over there and he walked in and he shook
hands with people you couldn't tell and you know he he didn't weigh an awful lot he probably weighed
165 pounds or 60 pounds or something he's a tall man and loose-jointed if everybody knows it
and that the reception went off just fine so
at one dinner party we had uh when this appalling was still alive
we tried to set it up in a nice fashion we had
another there were the Paulings and Lisa and me and another couple and I had been two more maybe
eight people but we had a first course with some white wine and I brought out the bottle and
poured the white wine and the wine has picked up the bottle and he says oh he says yeah this is
I can't pronounce this well we say and he says that's the same wine you served us last year
which why he would remember of all of the dinner parties it'd been to what wine we had saved him
at the dinner party a year before it beats me but anyway that was his remark it's been great fun
knowing it so does that answer your question about the papers and so on?
I want to ask you about the shoemakers we have their questions yes such a question
yeah you have a senior to broad what do you call it on what they're like is this people and that's
saying oh well Dave shoemaker and I were close friends and when they we served on a national
committee together the United States the American Crystalographic Association has a committee
on which well at any rate we had a meeting to which I traveled in Washington DC and Dave
shoemaker was the chairman of this committee well he and I had been students at Caltech and I knew
him very well and at the end before I left we were looking for a replacement for Bert
Christensen who was retiring and there was some talk given about bringing in in fact it was
preferred to bring in an outside person and I was impressed with how Dave who was on at MIT
as professor of chemistry and a crystallographer ran this meeting very efficient I thought she'd be
a good chairman and so the meeting was one one under a very very tight schedule we had we worked
furiously for several hours and then people had to disband and they were not having a dinner
they were going to go home so I had almost I said Dave I want to talk to you and he said well
he says you know I got to catch a train it's not so much of time but he says I'm on the way to
the restroom let's go to the restroom together well this may sound indelicate and when you
play it back again but there we were on a pair of journals which were at an angle to each other so
we were somewhere facing each other and I outlined this situation to him and asked him if he would
consider think about being considered as department chairman of course Dave grew up and
Idaho went to recall it so he loved the West and although MIT was a very prestigious institution
and they had a summer house so he had a plara up in the mountains he said yes he would think about
it so he came out and people liked him and he was off of the job well one of the conditions for
the job from his point of view was that his wife Clara Brink was also a distinguished crystallographer
and she wanted to be able to work to have an appointment at that time there was a law in fact
and there still exists that came into being during the depression it was an anti-neptism law
and it decreed that no members of the same family I don't remember how that was defined
could work in the same department or in fact in the same institution but even further in the
state system of higher education except under unusual circumstances well about this time
Lisa my wife who was also a scientist we've been working together for years and we had a joint
grant together and previous to that she had had appointments and computer centers and associate
professor and so on so she was a professional but then it was determined that by a birth
chrysanthemum that he wasn't going to allow her to work any longer and be paid and so I went to
him and said look we've got this grant here and then you've signed it on the bottom the line item
on the budget and Lisa has to be able to work he says I'm not going to approve it so we took it
over to Vern Schell of them who was being a science at that time and brought it in I showed him
this and he says well why don't you tell me this sooner and I said well birth chrysanthemum he
were very close friends and I said I thought we should be talking to the chain of command here
and he says well he says here's a document it's legal he says she's going to be able to work
on this grant until it expires but after that she's if she wants to continue to be paid she'll have
to be get a grant of her own well all this a privilege a day of coming and one of his conditions
as I say was his wife be allowed to work and uh this is heart McVicar came around and uh he
looked at this and he says okay he says it says that you cannot have members of the same family
working in this institution at the same time and being paid except under unusual circumstances
he says it's clear that a husband and wife scientific came as an unusual circumstance
so he says I am going to approve this and then they've said yeah but Ken Hedberg and his wife
are exactly the same situation and Nick Picker says the same rule of applied on them
and McVicar said and this is very funny uh here Dave and I are close friends and our wives are friends
and McVicar says the only thing I'm going to ask is that you be responsible for decent my wife
and Ken would be responsible for Clara so once a term David called me and there's
officers okay Ken how's Clara doing and we would have a big laugh over and I said fine I said how's
the lucid doing fine he says that that's it so that's the history of uh without condition
Dave excepted the job and was here uh certain that capacity for several years until he retired and
he and Clara had an office in chemistry about he became ill with kidney disease fun he was on
dialysis and died of a heart attack on time during dialysis over an Albany. Clara lived for
several years after that and they set up a fund anchored with a hundred thousand dollars to begin
with for the support of students in chemistry so that's Dave Schumacher uh Dave and I shared
an office at Caltech it's another interesting thing about him I have never been a smoker but he was
and uh I told this story at meetings when people will ask me about Dave I said well you know
he had uh he didn't have an astray because that wouldn't have lasted long he had uh
uh France 75 how it's so showcasing which is a brass thing with a rim on the bottom and stood
about two and a half feet high and it had a notch cut on the top and he'd sticky cigarette and that
flip it and the ashes would come down when he left that thing was folded a brim with ashes
in my office I threw it out of course but uh he gave up smoking right after that when he went to
MIT and Clara never smoked and she had some respiratory problems asthma and so on in her late
year so that might have been part of the cause they have a distinguished son the bobby Schumacher
who went off to Britain and he's an historian and he's at one of the uh southwestern British
universities and uh he believe it or not has a position as a professor of English history this is
an American he's still an American citizen and he's written uh his thesis was a penetrating book
a penetrating document was published in book form and got uh very very good reviews
so I think that's uh an interesting sideline to the Schumacher's both scientists the son of
his historian lecturing on any English history to Brits and being academically rewarded for it
but we talked a little bit about your early trips to Norway and your associations with
Norwegian and whether you could talk a little bit more about how that has continued every time you
mentioned Norway and Norwegian scientists. Oh well uh let's see I want to make sure that
I'm talking about the things you would want me to uh how I went to Norway and how my relationship
with Norway and Norwegians continued professionally through the years is that?
Yes we talked about the initial shift and uh how about what?
We talked about your initial shift in Norway and meeting you like the Christ and then
yeah uh your early associations with other baskets and then how to hassle
yes well um my professional associations with Norway
uh developed as a consequence of knowing professor Opto Walter Walshjohn
the leader became rector of the university I don't remember whether I'd mentioned that or not
yeah but uh uh when I was there I spent oh I've lived in Norway probably about five years
or so all told uh mostly on one year's stance and by the way Pauling has often come when I've
been there and we've escorted him around Bostjansson and I the various places in in Norway
and gone to meetings and talks that he's held and that he held uh at any rate uh at least his
family connections uh still you know early years of our marriage were pretty strong and uh she
liked to go back to Norway so on my first sabbatical leave uh at Oregon State uh I uh decided
I would go back to Norway we had some big projects going on uh that uh we could share Norway
with our Norwegian colleagues and so I spent a year at the University of Losswell then again
in sabbatical and Lisa worked also she came in and we had a nice house uh arranged for us by the
university actually it's an you know an apartment they don't have houses there by and large
uh for younger people so uh during this time I met a number of people that were essentially two
laboratories doing my kind of work at the one at the University of Oslo and the other at uh at
the University of Trondheim which didn't have that name at the time
and uh one of the uh Lisa got her training in uh Boss Johnson's laboratory and a number of other
people did also one of whom was a lady named Maudet Trenthabad who uh went to Trondheim became
professor there and I was invited up there and gave a lecture and she introduced me to a student
of hers named Colder and Hagen and Colder and I uh the question was he was just finishing his degree
and I was looking for a post-doctoral associate so I said to him out at I said well is he pretty good
and he said yes he's very good so Colder and came to the United States that was the beginning of a
professional relationship I think that uh probably my strongest professional relationship
apart from that of course it's my wife and the work that she does in the laboratory
of anyone and he has spent a total of six years in Kodala's coming at various times for years
leave someone once twice uh two-year leave and so on and uh
Sorry, Ben, how did he start his name? Just an actual year?
Hagen, H-H-H-E-M and the person in his cold urine uh
uh Björn is uh it's KOL and then BJ umlaut at O-R-M that means bear in the region
so anyway uh this relationship uh went on through the years and then one time
uh I received an invitation uh oh I was asked several times to serve on uh doctoral committees
and one of them was uh modest committee when she obtained her doctorate that was quite early
in my career that that was lots of fun because it's all done very formally you know there's a
first opponent of second opponent and then a third one who's kind of a humorous opponent
so I was the first opponent and in these formal things you're dressed very
formally on the old days used to wear tuxedos the candidate would wear a some hand would wear a
tuxedo but we had a podium and the candidate was over here
bought it and I was here and there was an auditorium full of people and I'd been given her thesis and
I would ask her questions and she would answer and so on and uh at the end by the way I was paid
a substantial amount of money for this and that was a norm for the time so we had a tremendous
tradition is that the successful candidate throws a party and we had a wonderful absolutely wonderful
dinner party at her house that's not formed an association that uh continued until her death
years later but she's been time and time and time is also at any rate so uh after uh in my mid-career
and uh colligerent group and inform me that the university had elected uh elected to give me an
honorary degree so I could come up there and uh and that was a tremendous fun also uh there were
three of us who won uh who were awarded an honorary degree and one of the guys was a
fellow from uh Germany who uh had just won the Nobel Prize so I felt myself in distinguished
companies and uh there was a big party I still think of that great funness and then uh I think
sometime before this I was elected to membership in uh an origin academy of sciences
and a bit later on another occasion a few years later these are the American Equivalents
uh the actual Norwegian name is uh uh well I don't have to describe it but anyway let's say
one of them's uh the Norwegian uh counter-part of uh uh national academy of sciences here and the
other one is uh Norwegian counter-part of the American Academy of Arts and Sciences and I've been
asked uh been awarded a membership in each one of these so all of this is a consequence of this
long stretch of uh professional affiliation I've had with people in Norway I think the
laboratory that does my kind of work in Oslo is now extinct and the one in the Trondheim is also
everybody who is involved in my day just as I am or is retired and so the university
efforts have gone off in different directions but everyone that belongs to this laboratory
almost every single person in Oslo I think barring one has been sometime in my laboratory
and almost everyone in Trondheim has also spent time in my laboratory so there's a
that number so oh maybe 10 or 15 people all together who spent as long as uh two years
in my laboratory I have a book in my office in which I formed the early habit of taking a
a photo of a picture and pasting the book and asking them to sign the name to it and all of these people
are there and on one occasion when I was in uh going to go to Norway I was asked if I would give a
talk in Trondheim and I said yes and I got to thinking about this so Kodrenhagen by this time
they've become a professor in Trondheim so I fished out all the pictures that I had and arranged
them in sequence from the time he first came the time he last came they're about eight of them
and I had a series of uh slides made of this when I came to talk I said I want to show you the
history of one of our good friends and so I put these up there and to the immense hilarity of the
audience because they'd never seen Hagen as a young man they'd only seen it and I could show
his development with dates underneath it well that made quite a hit in that talk he's never
let me forget about that even so it's it's been a great uh boon and fun for me
so I have also formed uh professional attachments and friends with people at the
University of Trond so which is in the Northern Norway and uh the University of Oregon I don't know
what's closed so it's it's been a very fun thing for me I think there was a name of people from
the OASU chemistry department over the years I'm wondering if you could share any recollections
about some of these folks uh John Fulton John Fulton is the only one that I never met in person
when I came to Oregon state in 1939 Gilbert was chair and I don't know how long he had been
at that point but he certainly was still chairman in uh 1956 my return and I think he actually
retired in from the chairmanship in 1957 wanting to spend the last truthy years of his life as uh
doing teaching and research again that's when Christensen succeeded in
so I uh every I don't know the Christwere you've seen all the pictures and chemistry have you
if you go into the main hall of Gilbert Hall on the end nearest here the library
and walk down on the left-hand side high up is a chronological arrangement of all professors
that have been present at this uh in that department and retired John Fulton is the first one in the
list every single person I have known of a succeeding 20 or 30 that go on down the hall
uh uh of course the last uh I've been retired long enough so I'm quite a long ways from the end now
but everybody on up to the present I've known them all except Fulton that's the kind of we good that
how about uh thanks for uh Gophelin sorry thanks for uh Gophelin Gophelin oh yes yeah uh he
he he he he didn't have an active uh uh role in the chemistry department he was Dean in the
College of Science and during the war for a short time he was uh acting president of the university
if I remember this correctly but he was a very erudite man and a wonderful personality
uh I didn't know him well I met him on a number of occasions and he was still alive
uh when I returned to the university but he suffered from I don't remember whether it was Parkinson's
or oh I think it was all some of the species that he finally succumbed to it but he was just a
wonderful guy his family has set up a uh research award and his name called the Gophelin Applies
and that's given every year to uh a faculty member
uh Earl Gilbert
Earl Gilbert uh the hall was not named Gilbert Hall until after he died because there was at that time
a rule against uh naming buildings after living people uh Gilbert was a a big guy
uh he walked with a kind of a shuffle he was a physical chemist he had two sons Henry and Allen
and Henry was a classmate of mine as an undergraduate and in the war broke out he was uh involved in
war work or over in Albany at the I don't know there was a bureau of mines in or whether he was
working with watching or whatever on war work but he died of uh of um a legacy
people think it was uh related to ingestion or inhalation of burilia which was extremely toxic
his son Allen Gilbert I mean his brother Allen Gilbert Earl Gilbert's son was a surgeon at the
Colales clinic for many years he retired uh as I understand it because he developed severe arthritis
in his hands uh he was a very nice guy well Gilbert uh I had only one course from him when I was an
undergraduate uh the department chairman actually taught them and he uh taught physical chemistry
I recall one kind of plundent experience with Earl Gilbert when I was an undergraduate
there was a chemistry honor society called Philan de Uppsalon and I was elected membership in this
and Henry Gilbert who was a chemistry major was not now Henry Gilbert was uh I want to say
a very outspoken outgoing guy and uh
he was not elected to when you're elected to membership of voters taken and if there is any I
don't recall what the circumstances of the election what the rules are or work at that time
but he was not elected and Earl Gilbert his father was very upset at this
and uh he called me into his office and he says I cannot ask you who uh he in a very
different way let me know he was very disappointed that Henry had not been elected
at that time the chemistry uh the Philan de Uppsalon had members comprising majors in chemistry
and chemical engineers largely and he says I can't ask you of course uh about the vote but he said
can you tell me this I suspect was it mostly the engineers that were involved in this negative vote
and I hesitated a long time and I said well you know I felt I had the answer and
and I said yes it was and he he he just shrugged his shoulders I know he deplored it
there was a strong greek community on the campus at the time that I was here
there was kind of a social division between the independence and the Greeks
and uh that uh division seemed to extend into honor societies as well people were voted for
membership and you know it's uh in retrospect it's utterly ridiculous to think that somebody who
is academically well qualified would be not voted into an organization for personality reasons
I like Henry Gilbert we got along just fine and he didn't have the shy respectful
attitude that maybe these people expected he should have but
that was very upsetting to Earl Gilbert another thing about the Gilbert's
uh once a year they invited the chemistry department to dinner at their house
but there's the faculty and other spouses and there was always a very nice dinner
now the Gilbert's were T-totalers no alcohol was served
to managers was served instead and that was all all well and good everybody understood this
then the Gilbert's went off uh I think uh
it may have been one summer they took a trip to France and they came back and uh
Wendell Sleibal a good friend of mine was hosting a dinner party and he asked uh
Elise and I were asked were invited as were the Gilbert's and some other people in physical chemistry
and uh it was a very nice dinner and Wendell asked me ahead of time he says do you think I should
uh offer people uh uh uh Sherry or uh a drink or wine with dinner and I said well it's your party
why not and the Gilbert's as I say I just come back from this trip in France so Wendell and Duke
of course asked everybody what they're in the pur and Earl Gilbert says well I'll have a
class of tomato juice and uh his wife said I think I'd like some Sherry
Gilbert wins and she had a glass of Sherry on the conversation and she said my that was nice
Sherry I like that very much and Gilbert modeled and I like my tomato juice too
I understood that uh I don't worry where I got this information but I understood that as they
travel through France they did drink wine because that's about the only thing that
you would be served at a meal and maybe that's uh how Mrs Gilbert just for the moment I
can't remember her name but it'll come to me uh they were nice people I like them
well the next first time I was in Wendell's label uh Wendell was a remarkable person
uh I held him in the highest regard not when I first came but later on
he uh well I first came did I mention that there was uh I mentioned that Christensen became
chairman after Gilbert but that was not without a hitch in the proceedings have I ever mentioned that
well for some god forsaken reason it was determined that the department should
uh not only elect which was so reasonable enough that should vote for who they would prefer as a
department chairman of course that was non-binding because the dean is the one that makes a decision
but one other thing for some reason it was nobody seems to remember this but me I'll have to dig out my
records the department decided it was going to have a constitution democracy was going to rule
now if you think about that how ridiculous can you imagine you can't run a department
has a democracy with a legislative that determines things you got to have a department chairman
of makes things happen these others at may slave all ran for uh he came around and I was new
at this time long a Tom Parsons and uh I knew that he was a candidate he came around and uh
and very subtle way was discussing this and uh chrisensen was the era parent as I explained uh
Berncello then was the dean and they were good friends and everybody expected that chrisensen as they
as the oldest and most experienced and long served longest serving department member
would become chairman he was a good scientist he did hard work and he's one of the few people who were
regularly publishing at Oregon State at that time well slave all was running also
and uh it was determined that uh the person who won the elections name would uh go forward
now I don't remember whether slave all won this election I don't know how many votes were cast
maybe 20 all told at 30 won the election by one vote
and all hell broke loose you know uh chrisensen was terribly upset so
and uh at slave all told me later he was invited uh over to uh a dean's office I don't know
whether it was show them and there's someone else and sat down and talked to in a friendly manner
by this official to point it out that he was a young man and that uh
uh the department would undoubtedly uh run better if somebody with long experience was chairman
and as a young man he would have plenty of chances to rise through the
uh hierarchy into administrative position and slave all reading the handwriting on the wall just
uh then announced that he was withdrawing his name from consideration that was his public statement
but his private feelings I have relayed to you so chrisensen became chairman and uh I think he
always had that uh uh what do I want to call it feeling of having been rejected hanging over him
for a long time so he stole very hard to be what he thought would be a good chairman and I could
tell you about that also but slave all was a distinguished teacher his lectures were very popular
and he had a most original mind uh he uh he did unusual things he built himself uh
was rare at that time a three-wheeled bicycle with uh enclosed in uh uh a canopy over the top which
had uh plastic windows in front so he was shielded from the wind and he would pedal this thing to
work and add a little flag up the back just as if you see some of the handicapped people using
these today not him he had this later on he built something similar and he put a motor on it
it was electric motor and operated by a battery he billed all himself he lived on uh on grants
street uh up about uh 34th street on the right hand side and he had hedges there
and he trimmed these hedges so what is the art farm known when you cut these in the form of shapes
and animals he meticulously groomed these plants and he had one sitting there that had wheels on it
an canopy and a steering wheel just one bush that had been sculpted into that shape others he
sculpted into animal shapes and then in his driveway which slipped down to the street he painted
one of the very famous uh uh what's the guy's name who does these peculiar drawings uh
they're famous now he's a famous artist the water that runs up hill without seeming to do so
it's the assure yes sure yeah yes sure he painted the the black and white doves that you know
mesh together not going down to the sidewalk he billed outside a bench into the wall
his yard sloped down to a concrete area there and he billed a bench in there a wood
and it says uh I don't remember the Italian words exactly or the pronunciation but say it
it's in a sense it's something commoto de publico for the convenience of the public you see
uh we got to know him and his wife uh very well uh later on we saw them socially a good deal
and uh Lewis his wife was a very nice lady uh Wendell uh he had this nice house
he had an idea he went down to the GT one time and he bought or brought I think he was
they were given to him a number of plates which were used in printing which were all black on
the top they were uh perhaps a glass or something I don't know but he bought a whole bunch of these
and he billed himself a box on his roof and he amounted these things so the sun would hit it
and he slowly circulated air through this which he then arranged to be pumped down into his house
and uh you still have to have a furnace of course but he said this uh noticeably reduced his
heating costs then and later years he would quit early and he says I need some exercising we'd go
home and I discovered he was digging a huge sister in his yard and uh I saw this thing being
constructed and he had grape lines in back too wasn't a big yard but he had grape lines as well
and when this was completed you know we were up there a dinner one time she's come and see my
sister and it was just completed and I looked down and this down thing it was about eight feet
across and it was at least eight feet tall it was a huge thing and he dug it all by hand
made the lining and everything and it's concreted it all up and so on and he said uh there it is
he says he's going to start filling it he says let's go down and he had a ladder built on the
side so we went down we sat down on a couple chairs in the bottom while he described this sister
into me so then we went upstairs and he covered it and he piped all the water that fell on his roof
all of that went into the sister which he then pumped out to water he's carton the front
and the vines and back everything and then the city then had a uh an assessment for storm for drainage
so he went down to the city and said he wanted to have his drainage reduced because the property
was not as big as they said it was and he gave him an estimate of the square footage of the
roof on his house and he wanted a proportional reduction in his drainage sheet the city would have
no nothing to do with this at which point he realized that this uh drainage was really a tax
on the amount of land that you had not really um it's disguised the way he put it to me
so that was Wendell
he died of a heart attack in his uh sleep and uh it was tragic thing lowest was very upset
and uh she continued to live in the house for quite a while and uh she would come to our house regularly
and we would go up there to dinner and uh she came to us for dinner and uh I did some work
a little work in our house for I repaired the toilet that was leaking around the seam at the
bottom put a new boat boot in it and I drilled a hole in the door and put one of these viewports in
it for did a few things like that and she developed an infection that uh by the time it was diagnosed
her uh condition was so poor that she even had to treatment uh she couldn't recover and she
eventually died from it not the infection but uh fact that uh she had no reserves left
so I was uh that's the story of the labels as I know they had one son who uh is in California
still he has no children and he is an orthopedic surgeon he had a daughter named Jane
who babysat our kids when they were small and uh she became for reasons that were never entirely
clear to me as strange from her mother and uh she lives in Seattle she was married and then divorced
and I think I've seen her once up there but I don't know what's become of her since then
that's about what I know of this label is you mentioned very Christmas in there uh
good to come and share oh yes well Bert very much wanted people to realize uh for the
convinced people he was a very good department chairman and we have in the chemistry department
at that time we have a source of chemicals uh let's call it a storeroom uh there's a lot of
chemicals used and at that time an organic chemistry and so on there's a big supply in there
and uh he would buy these in bulk and they would be repackaged in jars
and labeled with a number and so on on them and uh other departments you know they couldn't afford
a storeroom like this this would be sold to them at the price that was less or maybe just a
trifle less of the price listed for the same size container of the same material in the drug
and uh chemicals catalog and by buying it both and repackaging it we saved money
he made money and that money was used to support uh various things yet to realize on those days
there was almost no money for anything if you wanted to replace the equipment you know it was uh
like pulling teats to get any money from the university for that and this uh enabled things to
proceed uh in the department and to keep us just at least hanging on the trouble with this was
that this money which went into account had to be spent by the 30th of June and uh sometimes
Christmas was very frugal he would get all this stuff uh piled up there and then
he didn't have a way of spending it before the end so all sorts of peculiar things happened
he came down to me one time says Ken how'd you like to have your office painted
and I said my office painted I don't need my office painted and he says well you know it looks
little dingy in here we should paint a few of these offices and I just shrugged and so my office
was painted and that used up some of the money on another occasion he uh was walking down the
hall in the basement he says you know I don't like the look of all these pipes overhead this
in the basement everything was open all sorts of vents and pipes it looked terrible
he says I think uh well how would you how would you react to the idea that we put a false ceiling
in a masculine stuff I said well can do it if you want I don't see the need for it
and the fact uh it improves the appearance of things but it also makes it
uh substantially more difficult to locate the source of problems so a new course we have
that false ceiling which if you go into the basement of Gilbert you can see it's still there it's
got holes punched in it's white panels suspended from the ceiling and uh so uh
Burke was very very conscious of uh how I want to say he seemed to be covering his tracks all the time
and one of the reasons that he refused to renew my wife's appointment had nothing at all to do with
science anything like that she was paid very modestly on any event but for the first time in history
just before he took this action the city of Corvallis defeated a bond measure designed to support schools
and he thought why people are looking at what the education system is doing and here they're
going to see if there's a faculty member's wife who's being paid on a faculty member
being paid through the system of course my grants were to the university and they were paid
and he decided he couldn't tolerate the possibility of somebody objecting to this
and that was the reason that he advanced uh to me he says we have to be very careful of our image
he advanced to Lisa I didn't have any do with it she wrote him a letter went to see him
wrote him another letter and nothing had finally refused to answer her letters and that's when we
went over to the dean but I remember a remark or old Gilbert said one time he he was a gruffle guy
and he spoke down like he says he says Kristen he says bird is sort of like a country horse he
shies at a paper in the road so that's bird he uh contributed uh after he retired you know he
sent up a fund designed to help graduate students attend meetings when they were working in research
with research groups for which there was no money and that was used quite a lot and I uh thank
him a couple of times when I saw him on the streets and he says oh well I'm pleased he says
if he need more money let me know and I don't know whether he put more money up or not I was not
the department gentlemen so yeah these good sides
so that's a brilliant gentleman uh I don't remember much about
earn uh on uh on the same uh personal or intimate basis that I've mentioned these other people
because he was sitting in the dean's office at the time well when I first came here he was sort
of something he was out of something called the research institute and it turned out in the early
days there was a group of biochemists associated with chemistry among who uh who was uh uh
Shella and he decided that he would like to set up this independent entity
there are lots of reasons for it because uh overhead that was returned to these
uh agencies that that time the university returned part of the overhead to the departments
and the departments then could determine how they were going to use this returned overhead
well I think Vern had some ambitions that uh clearly he did he was a nice guy by the way
he arranged I'm sure with the support of uh chris and son to take these biochemists and to set
up what they called the science research institute which was largely biochemistry and then later on
that became uh I think uh kind of morphed into uh along the perhaps other departments I'm not
quite sure and what the department about chemistry and bio physics and then uh Vern became department
department became D pardon me he suffered from health problems serious ones he had uh very high
blood pressure at one stage and he died really rather young his life was uh very well known also
um was it I reigned her name was I reigned shella but I think she served uh
she was certainly involved in local politics and I don't know whether uh shella in middle school
is uh they were philanthropic also whether that followed mostly from her work or from them jointly
as a couple but at any rate so that's about as much as I know Vern person I'd see him on the street
when she can some chattabit and then I had this at least and I had this contact within the occasion
of her appointment and that's about all I had to do with him yeah that's my my list is Keralde
Keralde Kalk and yeah oh well Carol is a wonderful guy I regard him as one of the certainly one
of the better chairmen's that I have experienced here uh Carol had a research program in uh in
organic chemistry when I first came and uh he decided he would uh whatever reason I think his
research was slowing down that he would run for department chairman and uh I think that there
were two choices one of them was uh Dara Thomas and the other was Carol and I think the ultimate
decision was made by the dean that it would be Dara Thomas and after he served for a term Carol
became department chairman now Carol he really ran the department the way that a lot of
us would like to see it done he once professed to me he says look he says my research days are over
I view my role in this department as to expedite the research and teaching potential of the department
to the maximum possible and so he was know the difference between him and uh Christensen say to
choose an example Christensen you couldn't pry a dime out of him uh until the end when you saw
this flamboyant expenditures being made I'd go to Carol and I'd say look I need some money from my
returned overhead by the way in those days the department received returned overhead from the
university maybe they still do I don't know but the department to determine how what they did with
the overhead and our department had a practice of returning about 80% of the overhead that was
derived from the research grant of an individual to that individual so if you had a big research
grant of which a law of overhead was extracted returned with the department then you would have
a chunk of money to deal with because I think they returned 80% or so and you could use that
anyway you want now what happened was that a notice would be sent about that returned overhead was
now available and you should write down what your needs are now it wasn't that the overhead was
directed specifically to the individual who had earned it but that would receive some priority
but a lot of us didn't need all of our overhead and so we built up formally speaking an account
other people who needed equipment that exceeded the returned overhead could use the returned overhead
and then that you would have a credit so to speak well of course it's not a business and uh
so looking back a perspicacious individual would have seen that this can't persist and the guys who
have the credits are probably never going to realize there are money back again
whereas those guys who are in debt you know the department's going to decide they're not going to
distribute overhead anymore and so they come out and smell like a rose well I didn't need all of my
money uh because I was I had equipment budgets and I could buy an equipment apparatus that I needed
but Carol when I went to him on a couple of occasions saying I need this or I need that Carol and I
don't have the money in my budget for it uh he says how much is it I'd tell him he's he'd look
at this and he'd say okay go ahead buy it and uh he was very effective in this way and I think
people respected him for that because people didn't go to him to try to buy things that really
didn't need and this wasn't keeping with his uh professed remark to me as remarked to me that he
was going to do what he could to expedite the teaching and research activities of the department
of if you needed money for your research and you didn't have it he tried to get it for you
so he was very good uh you know he's still around he does we have an old man's lunch once a month
did you know that the old man's lunch started way way back in 1986 and it started with
bus marvel Elliott Marvel the professor of organic chemistry who retired and uh
Jack Dichius and it may have been Harry Frand also they decided they would meet for lunch
and then there were probably four of them all told and then when I retired they decided that I
would be invited for this and then it became a kind of a monthly affair and as people have retired
that uh has kept going so every retiree in chemistry uh and uh two or three in biochemistry
and bio physics Chris Matthews comes can then hold as a part of it
uh
Bob Becker comes then several chemists come several chemists who could come don't because their active tennis
player is still and they have matches Wednesday uh at noon when uh we have our meetings once a month
but I go regularly
and uh so Carol the cop comes
and he's a very lively guy it's uh lots of fun to see him he's been very active he bought a house
out on the area road he's been an active kayaker for years and uh finally he decided that the commute
for him and his wife was just too much so they sold that property at least in the process of
selling it and bought some last year here in town where he's now living but he's still kayaks
in fact they went down the road recently and he's been down the Grand Canyon more than once in
his own kayak so he's very active physically wonderful guy
what are some of the more group-ball group-ball memorable of things you can think about in 10 years
working with graduate students?
memorable experiences working with graduate students well
I'm thinking here as I'm sitting
I've had some very good graduate students and some that were not so good
but almost all of whom have uh finished and gotten a degree
let me name one who came along fairly late his name was Jin Fan Huang
and he was a Chinese national and he came here when oh I'd have to look to see but it's been
almost 20 years now oh perhaps even more than that from China when it was still a highly
restricted place and he grew up in the time of the cultural revolution and by his own boots
dropped, lifted himself up and he became aware of a position I had and I don't remember the details
but I decided he would be a good addition and I think he was coming at the beginning with his
own money so he arrived and I had several students working with me at that time and one of these was
a young woman that was working away when he showed up and I happened to be away the day he arrived
he came into the laboratory this young woman was trying to do some work on her computer
and he spoke a rather poor English at this time but he was as gong-ho as they could come
and after a while I think today or two later this girl came to me and said I can't stand this
guy she says over my shoulder all the time that's me all sorts of questions he was so eager
well by this time I was taking him in hand myself and he was beginning to enroll in courses
and he was a very anxious to start research and he was dynamic he was a tremendous researcher
and he was an older man and he had had a lot of work in chemistry even at the theoretical
that was very knowledgeable but he was required to fulfill our department requirements of course
for coursework and he enrolled in theoretical chemistry and he got straight A's no question about
at the end of his first year he was voted the outstanding incoming graduate student
and then a year later he was voted the outstanding graduate student and each of these carried
financial stipends not a great deal but some and one day he came to me and said
you know the Chinese are very cognizant of let's say I have a social hierarchy and the
deference which should be paid to people who occupy a status a little more elevated than yours
and so he came to me having just attended lecture and quantum mechanics by one of our
our faculty members and he said to me very quietly he said is it all right to correct a professor
when he's wrong and I said yes it is you should tell him or raise the issue and tell him about it
and say that you think this is the right answer but I'm not quite sure that he ever followed
through on that well he did a lot of work and then at the end of his graduation he got his degree
he worked for a while with dog Kessler in chemistry and then a colleague of mine at Michigan named
Larry Bartel was looking for somebody and I recommended Jim Van Wong to him and of course he shows
up and Larry isn't doing quite the same kind of work that I am and Larry has a very abrasive
no nonsense personality but I think he met his match in Jim Van Wong because he would tell
a long to do something and a long would do it but then he would point out he could do it better
this way and he would do it that way so it turns out that now one was married and he could hardly
wait to get his wife to come to this country and finally he arranged so that she could come
and they had two children two boys which is of course out of the line there
had any rate the first thing that the woman came he wanted her here so she could cook and he could
spend more time doing research and he enrolled his son in the high school his elder son
I guess both kids but I don't remember so much about the younger anyway he was very distressed
because after a while the younger son was not washing home after school and spending the
rest of the afternoon studying the son became quite used to American manners and he liked the
social life and so on and this distressed his father immensely expected him to behave like a Chinese
so he came to me with this problem and I said Jim Van said how's your son doing well he could
do better he could come home and he could be studying advanced things and I said well how are his
grades he said what grades I said well what are the marks he gets the courses he says well he gets
all these so it wasn't an upper Jim Van that his kid was excelling by Americans standards he had
to study all of these better times you see well the things went on his wife had to go home
or V6 fired and then he learned after she'd been home a long time that she was pregnant
at which time he immediately divorced her that's a no no there you see and I think I don't know
whether his sons had gone back or whether they stayed with him here or not I just don't remember that
but then he began to look for a new wife and this is kind of a mail order proposition
and so I don't know how the Chinese do it traditionally but at any rate he found some woman
in Shanghai and he went to visit her and I think they eventually married and she's a little more
modern type than he was and she joined even Minnesota and I think they're still there I don't know
whether they have any children together or not but he found a job in an industry and an
arbor but he still works weekends in Larry Bartell's laboratory so he's the most notable
graduate student from several points of view that I've had I've had postdocs that are even
just as remarkable one from Japan in particular we're getting on here how long do you want to go
I can I can go a while longer if you like
well let me talk about one of my postdocs I mean I have a host of graduate students and each one of
those has got his own personalities and some have been very productive some less productive but
I want to I want to mention something that I think is a remarkable
life or a pair of lives there was a distinguished professor named Yoneseo Morino
Morino in Japan at the University of Tokyo and in 1960 I think it was 60 it made in 62
but at any rate I wrote I had a letter or a rote letter I was looking for a postdoc
role appointer pointee and Yoneseo was called Morino we became friends and I've seen him all
over the world at meetings and in Norway and other places he wrote to me about his student named
Machio Iwasaki who would like to study and he could recommend him well now Machio came to
the United States having gotten his doctorate in Japan and he was phenomenal he was a superb
mathematician an excellent experimentalist he had only rudimentary English but I spoke slowly
and he could understand me and I could understand him well it turned out that when he knew he would
be coming to the United States in three months he had had no English experience at all
he and of course he had essentially no money they don't have money at his graduate students in
Japan at that time and so he went in hawk and enrolled in a crash course in English language
and he managed to get enough English so that he could speak to me in English in three months time
now that's very it's not so hard for a western speaking person to do that but Japanese is so
different that it's a tour de force he became much better as time went along so he asked me to
find a place to live which I did and it was very satisfactory it was very low level but I mean
after all he was here to do research he had his wife with him he had no children
and a few weeks later he came to me he said did I know a doctor he said well what's the problem
he says my wife has terrible pains in her legs and so on and we better see a doctor and so I
gave him the name of a doctor that we had used for our kids and he came to me the next day and he
said oh I didn't need the doctor we solved the problem the problem was that never in Japan had this
woman been sitting in chairs she had always been in the Japanese traditional position on her
knees and legs with her feet back like this the minute she started to do that all her pains
disappeared so she could sit on the chairs intermittently and sooner later the problem vanished
another time it came to me and says I need to have vitamins do you know where I can get vitamins
I says oh yeah you can find them in any store and he then told me well he didn't mean that kind
I said well what kind of vitamins do you mean he says I want like he says I take vitamins but I
inject them and I said well people don't inject vitamins there you can take them orally
and on another time he came to me and said that well you spent a year then he asked me if he could
continue another year and I said yes of course you can't so he worked very hard and then he came
to me at that year and he said I've been thinking about another apartment I said and he said I
would like to have you join me and look at it so it was over on Western Avenue where he had been
living on 11th Street in an old brick building there with apartment building and so this place
was lighter and more airy and it seemed to me I'm like a nice place and it was cheaper
and he seemed very hesitant about it and he kept looking at me and then sometime later he said
you wouldn't lose face if I moved here apparently in his mind because it was cheaper
it was a downgrade in quality when matter of fact it was an upgrade in quality but what is
remarkable about this is his having been raised in the time maybe it still was where face is
everything well the story is incomplete without my telling you a little bit about his wife who
is even more remarkable she couldn't take English she knew no English and she came here
she came from a fairly well off Japanese family very Western whereas Macho's family was very
traditional his father was an old sea captain and the daughter-in-law was expected to do everything in
the house they lived anyway she did housework for no pay with the stipulation that the person for
whom she worked would speak only English to her and try to help her understand the English language
and that went on for months and she became conversational in English in a halting way
then Macho said after his first year he says now I want to buy a car I want a car
so he passed the driver's license test I think he failed it once then passed it both the
written so many's wife said she wanted one but she couldn't read English she could only speak it
and of course they give you this manual with all the written instruction what the science
made everything she looked at the manual and with his help she memorized everything in the manual
she went and took the written exam and got 100% on it without being able to read any words
other than stop and slow and knowing what the science meant the other thing she did earned money
they wanted extra money so she heard herself out when the strawberry season came around to pick
strawberries that was a big thing in those days and she picked strawberries about twice as fast as
anyone else because she knew how to sit on her horses she could go along like a rabbit according
to my undersung she could pick these strawberries and they were paid peaceways for it she made
more money than anyone else picking strawberries well they went back to Japan I visited them there
on a most remarkable experience one time but I'll tell you
what happened to her they moved in with his parents and she had to play the subservient daughter and
when I was there with a friend and revisited them we were invited to the old people's house and they
they wore kimonos and as we came in the door we were professors my friend and I
and macho was we finished the travel that's another story they were on their knees with their
heads down like this because we were professors and we were assured in but modicol the wife of macho
did not eat dinner with us she served us she was in the kitchen all the time
after the parents died and they took over the house she began to do watercolouring
and as time went on her watercolours became very well known and then finally she became famous
when she died some years ago now not many maybe five she was the most talked about watercolour
stone all of Japan their paintings are in museums and she made lots of money from her pain
just an utterly remarkable couple I feel very fortunate to have known them
so that's he's the most remarkable postdoctoral person I've had from
these I'm how they're the people of scientifically excellent of course that's not really what I'm
talking about but in addition to the scientific excellence that macho had he had all of the other
things they saved money while I was here so they could buy an American hot water heater and send it
home and install in these parents house so they would have hot water and when I came to visit them
they were very worried about the toilet facilities because they only had the traditional thing
were a couple of porcelain raised footprints on a hole in the floor and you had to squat you see
so a remarkable insight into Japanese living
the occasion of this I can tell you this visit to Japan with macho
Autobotsyonson whom I mentioned before and I were in Japan for a meeting and preliminary to that
meeting we were asked by a macho or by some other the principal sir would we would you like to do
something ahead of time and I wrote and said yes we would like to like to look around Japan a bit
a week ahead of time there was a range that macho had a car now and was employed by an institute
and becoming a very well-known scientist would take us around in this car and the one thing I
said to him is that I didn't want to live in any American excuse me or English style accommodations
I wanted to see what Japan and particular rural Japan was like so as we traveled around for seven
days he had booked ahead of time accommodations and Japanese ends and all the time we were traveling
on this trip I never saw another Caucasian in these ends in which we stayed we would come in
there would be a doorstep we would be met with a hostess who would bow and give us our kimono
you know and take off our shoes we have a usher to our room and some
all snack bits after our travel would come and then a few minutes later the person would come in
and say your bath is ready the bath was not a shower it was a huge place this is more or less
than norm and there was a huge tub was about four feet deep and it would hold four or five people
and it was full of scalding water you see then there away from this tub is a tiled area
with soap along the wall and there's where you wash yourself very thoroughly and rinse yourself
then you got into the tub to soak then after a while you'd get out again and repeat the
process that's what a Japanese that's what we were treated to well then we got out and we were a
sort of how do you want to call totally relaxed with all of this we had a kimono we came back in
this was a Japanese room no beds nothing you know tatami on the floor a rice door
and then there would be a discreet knock and the horses would come in or one of the serving
girls would come in and her kimono bowing like this set up a little table put the stuff on it
and sit there and serve us pour the sake for us and my Japanese we didn't speak in the Japanese
of course but my Japanese friend much of would translate and he says if we like the service
we are it is a part of the process to offer her a drink of sake and so we did that and she
bowed gracefully and drank sake very nicely and then at the end they would blur all its
away and then they would haul out the tatami that you were going to sleep on bed so to speak the
role and that would be put out on the mat on the floor and then we would sleep and at the end
of every one of these rooms was a glass partition that opened on to a private very small not bigger than
this room Japanese garden beautifully planted with plants we went around to a number of these places
and on one occasion on a Saturday night the Japanese they're way out on the countryside the men
leave their family they go out there and they have drunken orgies and one of these places we were on
second floor and I looked out the window in the morning and on this beautiful green lawn were a
number of recombinant forms sound asleep you know where they had collapsed after a night of drinking
inside the Japanese don't look at drunkenness in the same way that we do I've walked through Kyoto
and there will be a guy lying on the sidewalk the cops come along and very carefully
picking up by the armpits dragging up to the wall and popping up right there and then walk on
well that's about as much as I can tell you on that but that trip
is something few Americans have ever experienced and when I came back to Tokyo
macho said you know if Lisa had come with you we would have had none of this service because she
would have been expected to perform it I told my wife that she said it's good she didn't come along
well as you look back then you're creating science what are some of the things that you're most proud of?
Well I think the thing that I'm most proud of Chris is that I've had what I think is a very happy
life and what I've done my childhood was I won't say actually impoverished but we lived through
the depression and portion of which my father was out of work and the notion that I would have
been able to do the things that I have been able to do would have been almost unthinkable for example
I've traveled all over the world I've made much more money than my father ever did and I have
kids that are successful at just and I've had wonderful colleagues and I've had a research career
that has kept me occupied even to date I don't think I could have planned it any better actually
if I'd had to set out ahead of time on the other hand when you look back on a long life you see
that there are certain points where you've made decisions in a retrospect you're very happy with
but at the time it was almost a flip of the coin for example I very nearly married somebody else
before I met Lisa and decided not to it was touch and go my whole life would have been different
I wouldn't have had any of the same connections and Lisa's gifted scientist I wouldn't have had
anywhere near the career I've had were it not for the many contributions that she's made to it
we sat down last night and had a conversation about a problem I'm having and he came to a conclusion
about it so you know how it is and I don't know the way I mentioned this maybe I did when I got my
full bride and cooking on fellowships to Norway the previous year I had applied for a full bride
fellowship the application received was received too late if I'd gotten it which I was led to believe I
would have if it'd been received in time I would have gone to Belgium I would never have had any of
this Norwegian connection my life would have been totally different except for that week or so
and getting the application in so when you're an old man like me you can think back on these
career changing decisions that you made so all in all I would say that I just had a very happy
life and it's still happy except I see my friends falling one by one that's a depressing experience
but comes through us all
thanks very much
yeah well I'm enjoyed it